opposition leader Morris come to breathe
the air freedom as is driven out of
yonder main prison why he spent the last
nine months hundreds of supporters had
gathered to see him walk a free man
chanting party songs on the other side
of the city he supported it earlier
gathered at the military tribunal why
he's been standing trial they wanted to
catch a glimpse of their hero mr. Campo
and other detainees arrived in the
convoy of prison vehicles to sign their
release documents opposition leaders say
the choice of court to try them in the
first place was wrong not good for the
Justice to admit the intervention of
executive as human right defender
I am NOT proud of what happened we
prepare our arguments against the trial
in front of the old military courts the
amnesty granted to opposition leaders
and supporters came just hours after the
end of a national dialogue called by the
president from the tribunal they were
returned to the Central Prison to be
joined by family members before heading
home the opposition leader had been in
prison since his arrest for leading
protests against an election result he
denounced as Fordland his party insists
the healing process can only begin when
certain reforms were carried out we
still have the problem of the electronic
system that means that we have to
discuss there is the concern to our
reform of the rotor system because we
have to make sure that that there is no
consultation on run for the next
elections if there's no no reforms of
the electric system now then we can be
sure that what has been happened to the
production will happen again long term
president Paul Biya
had promised to implement the
recommendations of the National Dialogue
that includes some form of
decentralization of power
to the regions it's sofa ordered the
release of nearly 500 prisoners
including those who fought against the
state many Cameroonians welcomed the
recent release of hundreds of political
prisoners and rebels they say it's an
important first step towards healing
divisions in the country the pressure
will now be on the rebels to do the same
but have so far dismissed the recent
government concessions as cosmetics many
leaders of the separatist movement
calling for the creation of an
independent state of Amba Sonia remained
behind bars it's not clear if they too
may regain their freedom soon already
some Cameroonian say the government had
considered too much harlotries al
jazeera yaoundé cameroon